Gwen Stefani lights up Las Vegas with
her man right by her side Khloe
Kardashian celebrates her 34th birthday
as Tristan Thompson unblocks her sister
Kim from Instagram hello everybody i'm
denny direct oh this is the daily denny
and gwen stefani kicked off her
first-ever Las Vegas residency last
night
let me tell you the hollaback girl had a
hella good time boyfriend Blake Shelton
was there who wasn't just by her side
he was front and center supporting his
lady and backstage he also surprised
Gwen with flowers now when made her
Vegas debut in front of a sold-out crowd
that got to witness the former no doubt
front woman blow through a 90-minute set
jam-packed with hits old and new at the
Planet Hollywood in Las Vegas before the
8 year old dazzled and six over-the-top
costume changes including wait for it
this cowgirl ensemble clearly Blake the
Oklahoma native has a rubbed off on our
California girl and et's Cal tonight got
the tea from Gwen herself do you strut
down in your little cowgirl outfit and
said this is a fantasy because you get
to do it in front of Blake Shelton
[Applause]
what did he think of the costume was it
his fantasy well I cut you know he's
like my bestie so I don't know you
mister I was trying to ask him we
haven't got to he had things like come
and then leave he's doing the blinds
today so he was like of Italy he's doing
the blind the blind auditions oh the boy
was at home putting up lights oh no he's
a fairly man and he could do that when
also opened up to the crowd last night
about how Blake has changed her love
life for the better and how music saved
her when her heart was broken I mean
there's a lucky in love but then there's
unlucky in love and I lost my ability to
have any confidence what was that moment
and how did you move on from that I feel
like everyone knows what that moment was
that moment happened to me a lot through
my my my love life and everybody knows
what my love life is because there's
only couple of them well you know Gwen
isn't the only one who has overcome
heartbreak it wasn't too long ago that
Khloe Kardashian had to deal with trifle
and Tristan Thompson but the couple and
the family seemed to be putting that in
the past
Chloe Tristan and her sisters are on
hand to celebrate her 34th birthday and
that's where it can't put the pressure
on Chloe's man to bury the hatchet all
right guys so what do you think it's
Khloe's birthday do you think I should
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
given Tristan's digital drama started
back in April after Kim addressed the
NBA stars cheating scandal on Ellen but
since Chloe chose to give him a second
chance a source tells et her family also
forgives him
well Kim the queen of social media
shared a close-up shot of the big moment
I think she was excited guys has for
Chloe she's not only celebrating turning
34 but she's back in LA with Tristan and
their two month old daughter true Clos
also shared these cute instant stories
of her baby girl with a it's my birthday
filter and balloons I think it's safe to
say the rest of the fam is just as happy
to have them home how excited are you
that Chloe is now back in LA that's so
nice to have her back oh I'm so excited
it was they came back on Sunday and I
just piled the kids in the car and took
them over to go meet their cousin true
and it was a love fest switching gears
now because tonight is the finale of
RuPaul's Drag Race Season ten and what
would drag race be without some shade
our Brice sander got the Queens to spill
the tea on the seasons worst fashion
moments were special moment I only get
to pick a wine just one
[Music]
the worst I would probably have to say
when it's been the sponge dress episode
wine mone exchange mone exchanging the
sponge we all love to hate this bun
dress the sponge dress
I'm so sorry mone it was a bad dress and
this fun dress was the greatest anybody
get that it was so bad that it was good
so this one's dress it's like Hanukkah
everybody in the world knows that I hate
that goddamn Tweety outfit I hate it and
I can say that openly because every time
I see H I give her a big hug I'd be like
girl it's good to see you again Tweety I
love you
you don't saying I am just modeling and
living my Tweety Bird fantasies
unfortunately Dusty's by the runway will
always be my go-to runway that just did
not really take place for me miss a
brown cow stunning I was like seriously
girl that was a spotted like that that's
a giraffe
I saw the members like Oh brown cows
Monique brown cow moment was a little
mess not a highlight of her life happily
my sister Monique mermaid it was
probably yeah one of my least favorite
things
calorie passed draft yeah I think that I
was a little unimpressed with Yuhas best
drag look because I know you all has a
different level of drag then we got to
see during that look sadly I'm gonna
give you real tea because you know you
want it I would say Cameron Michaels
gentleman diamonds look was behaved with
a glitter dot the couldn't fabric that
is literally the cheapest thing you can
ever put on a drag queen so that was
questionable since I went home on my
pink denim and diamonds I'll say that
was the weakest one least favorite
fashion moment of the season the Barbies
and the flowers miss Vangie I had to do
it sorry
alright the season 10 finale of RuPaul's
Drag Race airs tonight and we also have
the Queen's reliving the best fashion
moments of the season so be sure to
check that out I'll see you guys back
here tomorrow for a Big Brother recap
with some special guests I can't tell
you now but I'll see you tomorrow all
right
[Music]